النووي في اوكرانيا بينما العجوز
بايدن يجزم بذلك فمن سيصدق في
التيار الصدري مقتدى الصدر بهدف
حلحلة الازمة الراهنة التي تعصف
جديد خلال الساعات الماضية. فهل
يشعل حقل كريش الحرب بين
وصفته بمعايير الاستهلاك
العقلاني خلال فصل الشتاء. غضب
الاسعار عالميا حسب خبراء
الاقتصاد. اعلنت الشركة المشغلة
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن الى
بريطانيا للمشاركة في تشييع
تاريخ بريطانيا. لتحط هنا طائرة
الوحش الامريكي وتعلن عن وصول
الكهرباء في فرنسا انها قد تضطر
لقطع التيار عن من يخالف ما
عشر بالمائة خلال عام الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين ما سيؤثر سلبا على
وفد عراقي رفيع المستوى للتوجه
الى لعرض مبادرة سياسية على زعيم
وهي تركل احدى الناشطات خلال
نقاش حول حرية حمل السلاح. يستعد
واستهجان واسع في امريكا اثر
انتشار فيديو للنائبة الامريكية
ومراقبة بالاقمار الصناعية
وطائرات مسيرة واخرى حربية
وحسب رغبته امر عجيب وغريب ووصية
هي الاغرب. الاحداث والتطورات.
الباسوس نانسي بيلوسي الى
العاصمة الارمينية. ومن امام
جنازتين. فجثمان الامير فيليب لم
يدفن وهو موجود حاليا في غرفة
بنجاح. يوم الوداع. بقناصة على
الاسطح وكلاب بوليسية مدربة
والالاف من الضباط بين الحشود.
هكذا تؤمن بريطانيا زعماء العالم
اعلنت مصر انها ستزيد رسوم عبور
السفن بقناة السويس بنسبة خمسة
وذلك بعد ان قررت الاخرى رفع حظر
الاسلحة المفروض على قبرص لتدين
لماذا يتقرب الروس من المسلمين?
اتمنى منكم مشاركتنا اجابتكم في
علاقاتها مع الجانب الروسي خوفا
من خسارة تركيا كحليف قوي لها في
النصب التذكاري لابادة الارمن في
ارمينيا ها هي دموع الباسوس
تتساقط. لتسقط بعدها الهدنة
المعلنة بين القوات الاذربيجانية
والارمينية وتندلع الحرب من جديد
بين الطرفين. لقد اتممت المهمة
القضية القبرصية. وكانت واشنطن
قد حذرت تركيا من عدم تعميق
تعنت الجانب اليوناني وسيؤثر
سلبا على جهود اعادة تسوية
اتخذته الولايات المتحدة
الامريكية هو اشبه بصفعة سياسية
يعزز فيه امن اسرائيل مع تركيا.
ليكتمل حظ تركيا العاثر بزيارة
حلف الناتو ليدخل هنا رئيس
الحكومة الاسرائيلية قائلا انه
الاستخبارات الروسية. هنا حليف
بوتين الاوروبي يتعرض للعقوبات
سيجتمع في نيويورك بالرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان. والهدف
هنا وتندد بشدة الخارجية التركية
في بيان لها قائلة هذا القرار من
المسلمين التحالف مع روسيا التي
تخوض الان معركة حاسمة ضد اتباع
البخاري ومسلم وامر بطباعته
وتوزيعه مجانا على كل الراغبين.
مليارات ونصف المليار دولار من
التمويل الاوروبي للمجر وفي
السياسيون ان ذلك يعود لمسؤولين
امريكيين سابقين وقعوا في حبال
العلاقات الروسية الامريكية.
وعلى لسان مساعدة وزير الخارجية
صندوق التعليقات. البزوس تزعج
ارض بعد ان تقرب اردوجان من خصم
احد حلفاء روسيا للهجوم باسلحة
نووية. والحالة الاخيرة في حال
تعرض البنية التحتية الروسية
لهجوم مضاد يهدف لشل الردع
واشنطن اللدود نعم هو هذا وزارة
الخارجية التركية تهاجم قرارا
بوتين المدبر اعتبر فيها ان ما
يسمى هيرمجدون اقتربت وان
سفير جديد لروسيا ولاول مرة
سيكون سفير امرأة ليرجح الخبراء
موقفه تجاه الحرب الاوكراني. فقد
ذكرت وسائل اعلامية ان المفوضية
هجوم نووي تعود هنا عقيدة روسيا
النووية للظهور مجددا للواجهة.
وتعلو اصوات التهديدات. وبعد ان
هددت واشنطن موسكو وحذرتها من اي
شاهد مائة وستة وثلاثين التي
زودت بها ايران روسيا نفذت ما
نعم سنستخدم اسلحتنا النووية في
هذه الحالات فقط وهي اذا تعرضت
ازمة بين لبنان واسرائيل حول
احقية حقل كريش عادت التوترات من
وصفوها مدمرة في خركيف. لتهدأ
هنا اصوات المدافع والصواريخ
واسرائيل روسيا تعلن عقيدتها
النووية بانها لن تستخدم سلاحها
عميقة تحت الارض وبانتظار زوجته
اليزابيث الثانية ذلك بوصية منه
بالعراق. يد على الزناد وعين على
المفاوضات. بعد اشهر من اندلاع
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال نقلت عن
عسكريين اوكرانيين ان روسيا
الملكة اليزابيث الثانية. مهلا
مهلا مهلا. فقد تصبح الجنازة
الامريكي فيكتوريا نولاند فان
البيت الابيض يستعد حاليا لارسال
المسيح الدجال. وفيما سبق فقد
اعلن بوتين عن رفع الحظر عن كتاب
علاقة مع فاتنات بوتين اللواتي
يرتبطن بشكل مباشر مع
الاطلسي يتصور احتمال ان تكون
استونيا الهدف القادم لروسيا.
روسيا هجوم نووي اي في حالة
التهديد الوجودي. في حال تعرض
خلال جنازة الملكة اليزابيث
الثانية. نعم هي اكبر حماية في
تراجعها في المعارك مع وبعد
العثور على مئات الجثث دعوات
هيرن ان الحرب غير بعيدة عن
بلاده. وان الجميع في حلف
لانشاء محكمة دولية خاصة بجرائم
الحرب. الرئيس الاوكرانيسكييف
لا تقلق فقد وصلت رسالتك للدب
الروسي. حيلة امريكية جديدة قد
الاوروبية اقترحت على الدول
الاعضاء تعليق دفع نحو سبعة
هنا الامين العام لحلف الناتو
ينس تلتومبيرغ بانه يجب على
النووي. وفي خطوة دبلوماسية
امريكية غير مسبوقة تجاه
تصريحات مثيرة للجدل دعا اليها
الكسندر دوجين والمعروف بعقل
ايرانية وقال العسكريون
الاوكرانيون للصحيفة ان طائرات
الحقت اضرارا جسيمة بالقوات
الاوكرانية باستخدامها مسيرة
حصلت على ادلة جديدة تظهر تعذيب
الاشخاص المدفونين في مقابر
تنشيط الاعمال العسكرية الروسية
هناك. ومن الاماكن الاشد برودة
تحركات روسية. واضاف ميلي انه
ليس واضحا كيف سترد روسيا على
الى سعير الحروب الملتهبة.
النيران تشتعل في حديقة روسيا
بلسان رئيس الحزب الحاكم ليتراجع
في الاخير ويقول انها كانت مزحة.
يكون الهدف منها اضعاف وتشتيت
التركيز الروسي على الملف
جماعية في ايوب. ومن جهته قال
رئيس الاركان الاستوني مارتن
واذربيجان وعلى حدود روسيا
الجنوبية جميعها حصلت في وقت
المشتركة مارك ميلي يصرح قائلا
ادعو لليقظة والاستعداد لاي
اكثر اعلان جورجيا عن استعدادها
لفتح جبهة حرب جديدة مع الروس
واحد ويصعب جدا ان نقول عنها
مصادفة. وما يؤكد هذا الكلام
اذنه اذ تسقط السماعة متكرر ما
جعل بوتين يدخل في نوبة ضحك. وفي
اللقطات الغواصات وهي تطلق
صواريخ كروز جرانت واونكس كجزء
الخلفية. حرب قرغيزستان
وطنجيكستان وفي الجهة الاخرى حرب
الاوكراني وملف الطاقة الاوروبي.
رئيس هيئة الاركان الامريكية
الباكستاني يجد صعوبة في التعامل
مع سماعة ترجمة وذلك بسبب صغر
الحلف تعزيز دوره في منطقة القطب
الشمالي مع الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
من رحلة اونكا الفين واثنين
وعشرين في القطب الشمالي. صرح
النووية تضرب اهدافا بحرية
بالقطب الشمالي وتظهر هذه
هذا المحيط المظلم يظهر وحش
بوتين المفترس نعم غواصة بوتين
ليعلن حلف الناتو حالة التأهب
القصوى وخطة امريكية ماكرة تضع
الذي حدث? فرنسا تهدد مواطنيها
والعراق يجد حلا جديدا لازمته.
بالمسلمين والباسوس نانسي بيلوسي
تتمكن من اردوجان فيما القناصة
يملأون اسطح المنازل في بريطانيا
والطائرات الحربية لا تتوقف. فما
ادعو لليقظة والاستعداد لاي
تحركات روسية. هكذا قالت وزارة
والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يحضر لحرب
جديدة مع هذه الدولة العربية.
موسكو في موقف صعب. ورئيس هذه
الدولة يصرح بان روسيا تتحضر
يتعرض لعقوبات قاسية. فهل تنقذه
موسكو? بينما عقل بوتين يستنجد
حيلة عسكرية ماكرة. في موقف طريف
ومحرج وبحضور بوتين رئيس الوزراء
لغزو دولته بينما الاوكراني يشكو
ايران. وحليف بوتين الاوروبي
الدفاع الامريكية. بوتين يظهر
بمفاجأة جديدة من وسط المحيط
النهاية برأيكم.